California's first driverless buses
started rolling this month on the
streets of San Ramon near San Francisco
the electric shuttle can carry 12 people
six sitting six standing John Blackstone
was among the first riders to get on
board for a spin
most driverless cars being tested in
America still require a human ready to
grab the wheel or hit the brakes if
technology fails but the shuttle bus
making its way through San Ramon
California has no driver no steering
wheel no brake pedal it's the first
completely driverless vehicle license to
operate on public roads in California
this is a big day for us for Randy you
Esaki the head of the County
Transportation Authority this is an
exciting ride indeed
so this is a first we're not a public
street actually this is my first time go
after working for months trying to get a
license to be on a public street this is
pretty cool this is the way you foresee
citizens of San Ramon getting around San
Ramon's mayor bill Clarkson sees
autonomous shuttles as a solution to
both traffic jams and parking problems
fewer people will need cars every
parking spot here cost you X amount of
dollars to build or even more expense if
you build the parking garages seventy
thousand per parking spot that's huge
we're gonna do less major infrastructure
improvements widening the freeways and
those things that really kind of mess up
traffic for a long time now that this
driverless shuttle is cleared to operate
on city streets we know it won't be long
until some pedestrians staring at their
phone will step off right in front of it
will it stop it did but they are hoping
the shuttle will be a hit when testing
is finished and residents can start
riding for CBS this morning John
Blackstone's and Ramon California I know
it's a sign of the times I'm trying to
get ready for driverless cars trying to
get ready I know we got into elevators
right with much trepidation and took a
long time to sell the elevator